il ya la chanson quand exporter ses très
rares jeux là vous la chanson française
par très difficilement les cas sont très
rares mais on a un très bel exemple ce
soir
la chanson française qu'on a exporté
c'est je vais vous raconter l'histoire
c'est un garçon qui s'appelle manu
dibango qui qui et joue du saxophone à
paris depuis très longtemps qui est
connu de tous les musiciens et il a fait
un jour un disque pop son cameroun natal
et bruits exactement une équipe de
football et les américains sont tombés
fous de cette musique
et finalement on a exporté de la musique
typiquement française et vous allez
pouvoir le constater
manu dibango
[Musique]
d
ma grossesse
[Musique]
gbagbo
m
on en a eu
yasar
[Musique]
m
pour ça
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]